je souhaite monsieur mitterrand que vous
et votre parti ayez la même conception
de l'impartialité de l'état que celle
que j'ai toujours eu et qui a toujours
eu le mouvement auquel jacques
[Musique]
je vous ai observé pendant deux ans vous
me donnez là un bien mauvais exemple
mais je ne vais pas m'engager davantage
moi je veux je vous appelle il ne fait
aucune observation particulière sur
votre façon de vous exprimer vous en
avez le droit moi je continue vous
appeler monsieur le premier ministre
puisque c'est comme cela que je vous ai
appelé pendant deux ans et que vous
l'être et bien en tant que premier
ministre j'ai constaté que vous aviez et
se tient juste de le dire le très
réelles qualités vous n'êtes pas celle
de l'impartialité et du sens de la
justice dans la conduite de l'état
permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce
soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
république nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité
et qu'ils se soumettent au jugement des
français
seuls qui comptent vous me permettrez
donc de vous appeler monsieur mitterrand
et vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur
le premier ministre
pourquoi mitterrand et chirac
jeu d'abord parce que je viens si vous
voulez comme j'avais voté mitterrand en
81 jeu
socialement je me sentais dans le le le
vous voulez le camp des petits d'où je
venais voyez c'était une sociologie et
j'avais l'impression du du mépris de
classe de giscard à l'époque et en 88
je n'avais pas confiance dans chirac jeu
d'ailleurs j'ai écrit plus tard des
livres assez l'homme une semaine l'homme
qui ne s'aimait pas que dans 2002
exactement et je n'avais pas confiance
en lui je n'avais pas confiance en ses
revirements incessants
et vous n'avez plus confiant sans nom en
mitterrand non pas du tout pas du tout
donc vous avez raison je n'avais pas
plus confiance en mitterrand mais
fallait bien fallait bien choisir
je cherchais ma voix je vais vous dire
honnêtement en 88 je n'ai pas encore
trouvé ma voie politique d'ailleurs tout
ça est assez cohérent puisque on a vu au
début de notre conversation le
basculement qui a été pour moi
1989 puis ensuite donc il y a eu 89 le
voile de creil puis ensuite il ya eu 92
le référendum sur maastricht où là je
m'inscris petit à petit au fur et à
mesure de la campagne dans le camp du
non voyez ensuite il ya une logique dans
tout ça
[Musique]